De telescópios ao Grande Colisor de Hádrons,
cada nova ferramenta científica reinventa as perguntas
que nós, como cientistas,
e mentes curiosas podemos razoavelmente fazer.
A computação de alto desempenho, ou HPC,
entrou nessa lista de elite nos anos sessenta. Hoje,
os computadores quânticos estão batendo à mesma porta.
Bem-vindo. Meu nome é conducive to coffee
e sou engenheiro de software aqui na IBM Quantum.
Neste curso, nosso objetivo é ensinar estudantes
e profissionais como a computação quântica vai em breve
trabalhar em conjunto com infraestruturas de HPC
para entregar resultados computacionais.
Você vai aprender como computadores quânticos
e clássicos se comunicam e trocam dados,
como escrever programas que exploram ambos os tipos de hardware,
e como essa integração abre aplicações que podemos resolver hoje.
Você vai construir experiência prática com hardware quântico real
e clusters clássicos de computação de alto desempenho,
executando jobs quânticos ao lado de cargas de trabalho tradicionais de HPC,
e aprender a interpretar resultados com confiança,
além de identificar onde a aceleração quântica
pode genuinamente ajudar nos cálculos
e onde não ajuda. Acima de tudo, você vai entender
para onde o futuro dos computadores está indo
e o roteiro que nos levará até lá. Achamos
que este curso é importante
e oportuno, e acreditamos
que combinar essas tecnologias será essencial
para alcançar a vantagem computacional.
Isso pode ter impactos de grande alcance em setores
como a química, possivelmente permitindo
um design de medicamentos mais rápido e pesquisa de materiais,
em finanças,
para modelos de risco mais inteligentes
e detecção de fraudes, em inteligência artificial e aprendizado de máquina
para otimização de modelos. Neste curso,
vamos mergulhar fundo nos recursos computacionais,
modelos de programação e algoritmos quânticos.
Então bem-vindo e prepare-se,
tem muito a discutir.